bonsoir touria leurs visas n'étaient fin
2002 jusqu'au début 2003 l'héroïne
d'hannah fait divers dans les médias ont
beaucoup parlé et que vous raconter dans
un livre intitulé brisé sous titré en
prison à dubaï pour avoir été violée
voilà alors avant le tragique épisode de
dubaï vous avez déjà une histoire qui
est pas simple vous êtes né à casablanca
vous avez été élevé par votre mère
divorcée qui était infirmière à 13 ans
en vous venez en france et vous avait 19
ans quand un jour vous promener aux
champs elysées et là il est une
princesse saoudienne qui vous demande de
traduire ce qu'elle est en train de
d'acheter j'imagine vous sympathisez
vous devenez ami et vous tomber
amoureuse de son frère
vous ça s'est passé comment elle vous
emmener chez elle après un jour elle m'a
dit viens découvrir mon pays ouais
choses qui pour une musulmane à l'époque
j'avais encore la nationalité marocaine
et vous savez quand en tant que
musulmane en ai jamais majeur
où on est sous la tutelle de 200 paires
et quand on se marie on est sous la
tutelle de son mari en divorce andreu
des liens sous la tutelle du père elle a
réussi dans le sens où l état faisait
partie de quand même de la famille
royale de m'éviter voilà avec l'accord
du ministère des affaires étrangères
saoudiennes mais je suis allé voilà vous
prévoyez de vous marier avec ce prince
saoudien mais là le sort s'acharne sur
vous pour la première fois vous avez en
l'an 2000 un grave accident de voiture
passer six mois à l'hôpital beaucoup de
difficultés pour remarcher et vous
mettrez deux ans pour arriver à vous
tenir debout position verticale
c'était le miracle un même pour les
médecins quand je suis allé
pour la visite et que je remarche et ça
a été un médecin qui appelait un autre
pour dire mais venez voir le miracle
c'était
walt jamais elle remarchera mais même si
elle doit re marché sera avec une canon
avec des béquilles
et moi j'ai a franchi ce pain je suis
une battante alors voilà donc vous allez
cet accident beaucoup de temps beaucoup
de difficultés pour arriver à remarcher
hélas le malheur s'acharne sur vous
comme ce que votre fiancé le prince
saoudien décède
il avait 32 ans vous dites dans votre
bouquin qui prenait des médicaments sans
doute pour maigrir maigrir avant le
mariage avant le mariage est rentré des
états unis il avait eu son diplôme aux
états unis il a été nommé au ministère
des affaires étrangères à riad
est justement avant le mariage comme il
était fort il avait grossi énormément
aux états unis et on lui a conseillé de
maigrir non c'était pour me faire
plaisir aussi parce qu'à l'époque moi je
faisais que 45 kg sans acheter un
voilà alors là vous finissez ces
terribles finissez vos études de le
prothésiste dentaire
vous rencontrez un autre homme est en
fait vous gardez toujours en mémoire le
cas maintenant le souvenir de votre
premier mari enfin de celui effectué le
premier mari toujours
c'est le seul et unique d'ailleurs quand
votre enfant né avec ce nouvel homme
voulu donner le nom que vous vouliez
donner à l'enfant que vous vouliez à
voir j'ai tenu ma promesse avec le
prince saoudien et la province et elle
sera toujours là
et vous séparer de cet homme
les aléas de la vie là vous rêvez d'un
paradis et vous pensez à ce moment là
que dubaï peut être peut être ce paradis
et là coup du sort au moment où vous
allez partir à dubaï le malheur
s'acharne encore sur vous vous découvrez
vous est atteinte d'une maladie
orpheline
10 une affection neuro musculaire qui
s'appelle la myosites 1 c'est une
maladie neuromusculaire qui atteint les
muscles et elle fait évoluer comme elle
que stagner pour l'instant aller ça va
mais voilà on va finalement vous devez
prendre votre service à dubaï à vous
travaillez l'expansion économique au
consulat de france donc là tout va bien
au début à huy impeccable ça vous plaît
à c'est un pays moderne etc puisque
moderne ouais alors j'ai visité les
états unis c'est puisque moderne coin
alors aux états unis seniors et en plus
il ya ce mélange de cultures que je
recherchais parce que on se recherche
automatiquement faut pas oublier que je
suis d'origine arabe alors
automatiquement on cherche ses origines
le pays on a grandi alors ya une culture
orientale une culture occidentale et je
les retrouver là voilà et là
effectivement la veille de votre
anniversaire vous êtes violée par trois
emmy rien c'est ce que vous appelez dans
votre bouquin l'enfer du décor vous
dites nuit d'horreur
il vous emmène en voiture dans un
quartier résidentiel dans une maison
où il avait prévu de faire ça c'était un
coup monté c'était pour eux c'était fait
pour
il avait téléphoné entre temps pour
préparer leurs cours
et je me suis retrouvé là vous découvrez
en fait que dubai sous ses jours comme
ça ultramoderne en fait cessé
c'est bien beau de maintenant mettre
plein les yeux ouais et voilà c'est le
revers de la médaille alors ce qui est
terrible c'est que le lendemain vous
avez porté plainte et finalement ça se
retourne contre vous et ses skis car
après ça soit la contre c'est ça qui a
fait le giro c'est pour ça qu'on a
beaucoup parlé de votre votre affaire à
l'époque parce que j'ai porté plainte
pour viol et finalement vous êtes accusé
de relations sexuelles hors mariage je
veux dire quoi
alors si on traduit mot à mot en arabe
de l'arabe
en français
s'est violent avec consentement ouais ah
oui c'est nouveau ça oui c'est violent
avec consentement mot à mot
allah c'est le choc mais c'est grave là
bas ce délit de relations sexuelles hors
mariage c'est c'est très grave pauvre
mais moi j'ai été surprise quand j'ai eu
je me suis retrouvé en prison j'ai vu
une fille qui avait maintenant avant
elle aussi elle s'était fait enlever
violée elle avait reçu des coups de
couteau
il avait lâché en plein désert
cette fille s'est retrouvé sur la route
elle a eu la force d'arriver sur la
route il ya une voiture qui passe qui la
prend et qui l'emmène à l'hôpital
arrivée à l'hôpital on lui pose la
question qui s'était passé elle raconte
sur l'histoire on l'appelle la police
justement pour faire un rapport et ça
faisait neuf mois qu'elle était en
prison pour rapports sexuels hors
mariage
voilà bah vous retrouver en prison et
puis en plus quand vous sortez de prison
vous êtes en liberté conditionnelle vous
n'avez pas le droit de quitter le pays
ce qui est une sorte de prison sont
prises en mairie horizons et là
commencent les auditions les
confrontations les interrogatoires et le
consulat de france ne vous êtes pas
beaucoup on pense que c'est aux au nom
de la raison d'état pour pas avoir de
mauvaises relations avec dubaï je vais
être franche je travaillais pour le
consulat en quelque sorte entre
guillemets un je vais mettre ça entre
guillemets je travaillais ou noir moi je
ne savais pas alors qu'ils avaient
normalement avant de me proposer ce
travail il fallait l'accord du ministère
des affaires étrangères et l'accord du
quai d'orsay il n'y avait pas cet accord
le jour où j'ai eu le problème ils ont
essayé de camoufler cette histoire la
seule chose qu'ils en trouvent aient à
faire
c'était parce que quand on est venu me
voir en prison j'ai demandé de faire le
check out de la chambre pour que bien
sûr que la facture ne 1
la première est est ce qu'ils ont trouvé
à faire c'est enlevé l'épreuve
de mes missions c'était marqué bien sûr
mon nom mon prénom l'adresse du consulat
et tampon du consulat
dont il est plus de raison d'être là bas
et on pouvait facilement vous accuser
d'être là bas pour d'autres choses que
l'expansion économique de la france
actuellement là parce que s'ils avaient
intervenus j'aurais même pas fait cette
semaine de frein
parce que pour les imériens j'étais là
je faisais des allers et retours je suis
d'origine marocaine automatiquement mais
on fait le lien via un réseau de
prostitution book oui voilà parce que
les prostituées souvent dit vous dans
votre livre sont marocaines là bas
il n'ya pas que les marocaines ya de
toutes nationalités mais
elle sent plus célèbres pour ça c'est
les plus riches c'est le plus bas on va
dire
c'est celle qui sont payé le plus cher
alors en france heureusement il ya un
comité de soutien qui se met en place
les médias sont sont alertés le monde
libération et puis voilà six mois plus
tard vous finissez par rentrer en france
mais vous êtes condamné en fait part par
dubaï vous êtes condamné à six mois de
prison par contumace donc en fait là
vous êtes sous le coup d'une
condamnation
émirati un
oui je suis qu'on a aimé il faut pas
oublier quand je suis rentré après un
mois un mois après mon retour on m'a
proposé de me payer toutes mes dettes
parce que je suis endetté depuis je suis
rentré bien sûr il fallait
non non la mangue sait rien du con mais
je suis endetté par rapport aux frais
d'hôtel par rapport à tous les frais les
frais qu'il y avait ici faut pas oublier
j'ai un enfant j'ai j'avais même en
appartement il fallait continuer à payer
ici aussi et je me retourne je me
retrouve endetté et voilà qu'il ya une
personne qui fait le lien soit disant on
sera jamais
qu'elle ya un fait si elle fait partie
des imériens on voulait d'état français
ça on saura jamais qui m'appellent et
qu'ils me proposent comme paye toutes
mes dettes et quand même être un peu
d'argent pour passer les vacances avec
mon fils mais à condition ne pas écrire
mon livre
et moi ça a été un refus étant donné que
moi mon livre c'est ma psychothérapie
je ne cherche pas à gagner de l'argent
la seule chose que je cherche c'est un
témoignage
pour dire ce que j'ai vécu et à
encourager toute personne qui passe par
là parce que ça doit être dur d'idées
isolé des femmes qui passent par des
viols et qui arrive à garder ça pendant
des années
j'ai essayé
on m'a déposé mon hôtel lutteurs du bape
et
j'ai essayé de garder ça pour moi je me
suis lavé relavé je suis allée acheter
des produits pour me laver on se sent
salie c'est pas possible
moi je comprends pas les femmes qui
attendent des années pour déballer
alors ce qu'on apprend dans votre livre
quand même que vous n'aviez pas dit à
l'époque c'est que le soir du viol donc
le 14 octobre 2002 la veille de vaud 39
ans vous aviez eu une altercation dans
une boîte de nuit vous étiez allé boire
un verre c'est avec le cci voilà et
c'est les mêmes c'était le jour même si
je sais bien ce que je dis mais vous
allez dans cette boîte de nuit tout seul
bon c'est vrai que là bas c'est
peut-être surprenant ici sales et moi
non je tenais simplement à bon tu
touches connais pas les moeurs du tout
quand on arrive là bas envoient
les cafés ou sur les terrasses de café
vous avez
des femmes habillés en short débardeur
qui sont en train de fumer des
cigarettes dont il est encore vous avez
causés dans cette boîte le la veille sur
tf1 ce soir là c'est normal vous y allez
vous êtes là il ya trois garçons qui
s'approche de vous donc et qui
commençait deux insultes moi je me suis
quand ils ont commencé à m'insulter je
me suis retrouvé vous ne connaissez pas
est-ce que vous connaissiez mondino et
là le gérant intervient on leur explique
en attendez
c'est pas parce qu il me traitait de
marocaine de prostituées de sites
étaient dans ton pays tu aurais pas fait
ça et là le gérant intervient en disant
mais attendait
lé pa marocaine elle est française et
elle descend chez nous par le biais du
consulat
et c'est là qu'il y en ait un qui qui se
lève il me présente ses excuses
et je me dis pourquoi pas l'erreur est
humaine n'importe qui peut faire une
erreur peut-être que c'est vrai avec le
réseau de prostitution qui existent on
peut faire l'erreur
mais ensuite pourquoi vous monter dans
la voiture si cette confiance après ce
qui s'était passé malgré ça vous monte
quand même dans la voiture c'est la
confiance quand on présente des excuses
moi je pars sur le principe si je
présente des excuses à quelqu'un c'est
très prudent il n'y a plus il n'y a plus
rien turia c'est très imprudent est-ce
que vous en france est-ce que vous
l'auriez fait ça si on m'a présenté des
excuses je vais peut-être dû trop naïf
un peu mais je me suis je suis bonne
poire je le suis je ne parlais pas
physiquement mais je le suis au fond
- est maintenant bien sûr non vous
monter dans la voiture malgré ce qui
s'était passé avant moment présenté des
excuses c'est bon l'erreur est humaine
si des jeunes d'une vingtaine d'années
parce qu'ils veulent d'une femme de 40
ans dans le sens où les prostituées dans
16 17 18 ans et qu'elles sont là c'est
un terrain qui est très ouvert qui
y en a partout maintenant aujourd'hui la
boue regretté va porter plainte
regretté oui et non oui et non
oui pour ce qui m'est arrivé parce que
c'est moi qui ai payé et non parce que
au moins ça arrive et ça va réveiller
des esprits ça m'a réveillé beaucoup ça
fait pas mal de gens oui exactement
surtout ceux qui vont à la main pour en
vacances parce que quand on arrive en
vacances c'est c'est la liberté on a
l'impression c'est la liberté et moi
pour moi liberté est égal à droit en vie
dans un pays de liberté j'ai vécu dans
un pays de liberté et pour moi ça a
toujours été liberté est égal à droit ou
alors est un malaise et hypocrisie ouais
voilà c'est cette histoire que vous
racontez touria tiouli dans un livre
s'appelle brisé en prison à dubaï pour
avoir été violée et c'est publié chez
michel lafon et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de finale andy tube abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux